welcome to this video playing Zeke Motta
like Marta from Turkey and maybe let's
go back to a to a Slav with a six yeah
the Chawan Inc oh yeah people follow
what the top guys do Kramnik played g3
in this game against and raking in the
candidates ok it didn't really get much
but it's an interesting line I have
played it to myself as white
yeah this is a not so popular set up for
black but it seems to be okay to me I
have produced this video series on icc
on black repertoire based on the
calcutta in the Slav and this was my
recommendation I'm not sure anymore
about this concrete position really
forgotten us some of it of my analysis
and take with the pawn or with the light
and take with the night yeah maybe it
makes sense to get this exchange but I'm
not sure really I think 90s maybe you
can play 94 actually idea to go to us
yeah it would have been interesting and
the idea was to play 97 next but I just
recognized that he's got knight c6
coming against that all the time and
that's that's really not great and
that's an additional problem yeah this
is somehow chrome later played this idea
okay it looks it looks uncomfortable but
i think i need to do it otherwise i'll
never get my my pieces out that's not so
bad i mean he's not exactly a meeting me
quickly because my fee and shattered
bishop is missing I don't see that
happening so quickly if at all yeah I
can take you five but should I really do
that I don't want to I don't want to
give give this Bishop more scope
rather complete my my development team
what I'd like to manage to get in we
wouldn't have been would be deform I'm
Bishop b5 very normal rules I wonder if
I actually can play the bishop out of
the pawn chain now or is this is this
insane d for Bishop d5 is another idea
as mentioned before and not sure let's
try it
yeah phia retic Lee speaking white can
try to win a pawn now taking twice on c6
take only seven but this looks really
crazy Bishop e3 and other moves yeah
that's that's more more frightening not
really nice
no that's strong move freely
I don't know what to do really my day 7
something like that wow it looks
terrible
I don't get Bishop b5 and this whole
setup is completely ridiculous Jan yeah
this also looks like a terrible move
early I didn't see anything it's a it's
really a tricky are any you can just
take on c8 ok now that's good as well
it's not like this is so Wow
yeah I'm just clearly were say whatever
I am doing the default point is almost
doomed and e7 is also on that tech you
can just take here takes Queen takes
Queen d4 takes knight takes Bishop c5
and that's it just um just disaster
let's not do it's not playing that for
whatever reason um no not that this is
necessarily bad but I don't know if it
is necessary yeah okay
it still should be good for white can
maybe take knight takes Bishop c5 d4 and
then pick it up check yeah Queen takes
it's got both captures a good all night
and I Texas also am NOT a happy move but
what what else is there maybe I can do
this actually before Bishop c4 would
really help me no I got that in he might
get the pawn here but this is so I wow
this this this was bad by white I'm
still alive here
the night on c8 is just we are really
terrible money to get this into play
should I cover now I can cover that for
the moment
where to go then my TM to a 726 I don't
really know what the destination is at
the end time I'm trying time morning
oops this is I coming at a bad moment
okay so what about this end game is this
end game lost or is this a fortress we
will enter any way no way no way to
avoid it
hmm Wow before was really good I don't
get the nitrous e6 and then this is just
a loss simply as that or he had really
left me hidden again on this game and I
spoil it again this was bad really
really bad player him while frustrating
he is no no it's okay again check check
check no I mean winning black for fix oh
yeah yeah i work every time the time
issue at the end but decade was totally
lost of course he just played it very
very badly from a technical point of
view after f5 not capturing is just what
why don't you just capture I mean white
check it's just it's just completely
over but I needed to play a fight i have
no other move and this is just just
complete nonsense oratory but you need
to take open the position for your
bishop this is resigns
this is also resins but I needed to do
it and he didn't do he didn't play that
instead after after a couple of more
moves this is this is this is again
completely okay for me not even worse
this position but yeah what did that was
bad I mean after that I'm back in the
game really yeah just Knight to c6 is
correct probably I need to get it to c6
any 95 as real nonsense I need to get it
to see six anyway the problem is that of
course he still fights for for the win
here with the pawn but I need to control
default badly in terms of a queen trade
in case of a queen trade so that I can
prevent his King from invading d 4 C 5
p-6 and probably I can I can I would
this if the Queen's are traded it's not
fun but if it it might be might be a
terrible this this end game yeah but I
really this d4 idea i was i was like it
was like really bad Luke c5 was a strong
move I mean I'm glass here anyway but d4
d5 was just very strong yeah it simply
wasn't wasn't great him I probably need
to take with the pawn him yeah i don't
know i have forgotten that had forgotten
my own but when opening a recommendation
this is normally quite okay in this line
for black it's not like great but it
should be only slightly worse or equal
alright thanks for watching